thank you
good afternoon and welcome my name is
chris leslie the director of resources
and in the absence of a chairman and
vice chairman i'm opening proceedings
this afternoon
in a moment i will call for nominations
for chairman of this meeting
members before we proceed can you please
ensure your videos and microphones
are turned off thank you can i
now ask any member of the committee
wishing to nominate
to the position of chairman for this
meeting to please
unmute your microphone turn on your
video
and state your name and nomination
hello um i
i nominated councillor swain at 40.46
seconds into the call
before any other nominations were
received thank you okay
so let's go through this
we have councillor durham are here as
well and council lagging new nominated
story
okay so i've got uh councillor swain
and absolutely have i got any others
well um counselor darren was seconded
yeah
the others weren't i i just seconded uh
um councillor swain
okay so we have a second of the
cancerous way and we have a second
for councillor durham so we have two
nominations uh for for the place
we're going to take them uh one at a
time
um through this and
can i ask
tara we got um councillor lagan's
first nomination is that uh
i think it was the first to nominate but
could we have some confirmation tara if
you've got any or and then we take
councillor
swain first and then cancel it down
um i haven't got confirmation in the i
can't see the chat function
um that everyone sort of put their
microphones on at the same time so
um yeah i think whichever
everyone was actually yeah i think um it
wasn't clear to me who the others were
because we were all obviously speaking i
would say at the same time
but i hope definitely counselor sub uh
second councillor durham
two just to be clear sorry it doesn't
matter
there are two nominations chairman that
we simply have people voting for
one and for the other absolutely yeah
correct correct so we've got two
nominations both are seconded
got a nomination for councillor swain um
so if we take
i'll take councillor swain's nomination
uh first
tara could you uh please go through and
take the vote for councillor swaying
and then depending on that we will go to
uh councillor durham if uh
if that is unsuccessful
yes of course members i call your names
that alphabetically if you could just
indicate for against abstaining and this
is for councillor swain
as chairman starting with councillor
bamford please
okay and for just to clarify
substituting for
um council mrs fleming against
tara thank you this is chana against
thank you councillor durham
nothing personal councillor swain
against councillor edwards
for thank you councillor hull
maze
paul thank you council shauna c
four thank you councillor schemes
for
mrs thompson again
um so the result of that vote uh mr
leslie is six
four four against and one abstention
thank you so counselor swain
is the chairman by that
vote in torah and i will hand
over to councillor swain
um thank you mr leslie
um and um i'm
quite happy to share this meeting um but
i do not have the um
requisite um notices and information uh
to start with um
but so i will um i don't know if tara
has got
a basic script that i can work to or
whether she could read it out for me
item one sherman's notices
but bizarrely i have it to hand but
there you go
i think we all have i didn't a german it
was circulating
to everybody it was sent to everyone yes
on our emails
i can read it out if that is is what
you'd wish
and so
sorry chairman are you are you asking
tara to read the whole
of the script out um yes please
well uh well
notices and i can um i can cover them
adequately even if i'm not using
precisely the same words as every other
chairman
okay chairman uh so under chairman's
notices and just to remind everyone the
meeting is held
under new regulations which came into
force on the
4th of april and in response to the
covis situation
and would it be helpful if i actually
read out the housekeeping rules for
for you yes ok thank you
um so everyone in the present in the
meeting is asked to ensure that their
microphone
is muted and the video feed is off when
not addressing the committee
and this just helps reduce background
noises and
any unintentional disturbances the
meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded and by being
present in the meeting you're giving
your consent to being recorded
and members and offices during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
and the chairman will then invite you at
the appropriate time
and members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave the meeting
the chat should not be used for
questions or for any other
purpose please do not use the raise
hands function as this is not available
on all member devices
and when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers
please ensure you reference a page or
paragraph number
and lastly if members need to leave the
meeting at any point
and please make this known and use the
chat function to signify that you need
to leave the meeting
and chairman then the next process is
introduction of offices followed by
members attendance
thank you yes thank you
thank you tara then secondly
um
can we um identify the officers who are
present in the meeting
starting with mr leslie
chris leslie director of resources
thank you um did i
see um mr dodson as well
good afternoon members paul dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance
and uh was mr lee did i see mr lee
thank you chairman yep i'm matt lee and
i'm lead specialist for place here at
mdc thanks a lot
um and i think um
who else um what other who else other
officers are present please
chairman mr holly is present i believe
[Music]
mr harley good afternoon chairman
uh i'm fraud holly i'm lead ict
specialist
thank you i think another question is me
tim elsie i'm tara bird i'm the
committee services officer thank you
thank you i i think initially i saw some
other officers as well
available is there any other officer in
present
the chairman that is all the officers
present
all right thank you um then can you uh
make a carry out of old call of members
who are present
yes chairman of course and members if
you i'm going to call the names
alphabetically if you could just
indicate if you're present by turning on
your um
microphone please and council mrs
channel
yes i am present tara
councillor durham present thank you
councillor edwards present councillor
hull
that's the lagging
uh presents horrible members and
cheering but apology i might have to
leave the meeting early
thank you very much councillor mays
president tara good afternoon destiny
thank you councillor shaunicy
present tara thank you thank you
and councillor skeens present tara
thank you that's the stilts
present thank you councillor swain
in the church councillor mrs thompson
president tara thank you thank you uh
and councillor
and miss white sorry councilman white is
giving her apologies and councillor
bamford
present time could i ask if there were
any other members in attendance if they
could just advise please
good afternoon and welcome councillor
morris in the house
thank you cats
tara cancer stamps in the house too
thank you very much cancer stamp
um do we have any apologies other than i
think you mentioned councillor white
um yes chairman apologies from
councillor mrs fleming
councillor siddal and councillor miss
white and councillor bamford is
attending as a substitute for councillor
fleming thank you very much
thank you
the um next item then is the minutes of
the last meeting on the page
can i ask a question chairman please
sorry about participants
yes um well i don't know chairman if you
can answer
perhaps miss bird when i've gone on to
participants
um to show which i thought for this
meeting i see a whole host of other
councillors names or is that not correct
now with the new teams
does it show more than they're actually
in the meeting
chairman would it help if i respond to
that for you and the participants list
that you're seeing on teams
shows all those members that have been
invited and as members are aware the
invites go out to the whole of the
council
and so you will see everybody listed but
you should also see though a list there
that shows those are actually
in attendance attendance and those that
are presenters it should be split into
into three different lists for you no
can't seem to see that
no okay i seem to have one long list
some with yellow little things
some with green so don't worry about
i'll translate that out later i appear
to only have one list i think
okay we i can certainly look into that
for you councilman
they have the same replay
i think the green means i think the
green means that uh you're that they're
in the meeting
yes that might be the case but i think
what it does is might cause difficulties
chairman if people are raising hands or
not it doesn't allow you to see perhaps
all that are in the meeting in one go
before i could see all the participants
in the relevant meeting and you could
see if they were sticking a hand up or
whatever or take i know you said don't
use it but sometimes they did
so that was all really okay thank you
it's a bit confusing that was all it was
easier much to have just the committee
participants
that were there on the screen
right okay thank you so we proceed
um as far as uh indicating we should
speak is concerned
um i'm quite happy to um uh
see any hand raised but also
i shall um ask tara if she has got
others that appearing on the chat
function um so we can cover both
routes and make it a bit quicker perhaps
um item four was then disclosure of
interests
um to disclose existence in nature of
any disclosable
pecuniary interests other peculiar
interests
or non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
we regard paragraphs six to eight of the
code of conduct for members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such
interest as soon as they become aware of
it should the need arise
during the meeting
uh do we have any declarations of
interest
curses
[Music]
thank you chairman yes i have a
non-pecuniary interest as a member of
essex county council
and i am the deputy cabinet member for
economic development which includes
planning which is obviously relevant to
the second item on the agenda
and thank you
channel uh chairman i declare a
non-pecuniary interest also as a member
of
a sixth county council um i i hope you
did see that chat because i couldn't
find the boxing issue all the names
covered it but i just sort of hit the
bottom where
something seemed to be in the bottom so
i'm hoping you saw it
[Music]
um has anybody else indicated they wish
to declare an interest tara
um no chairman but just to advise
chairman we have missed the minutes of
the last meeting off
we need to go back and do those but i
haven't got any other indications of
wishing to speak
no okay well that gets the
administrative stuff out of the way
um intro item three the minutes of the
last meeting
to confirm the minutes of the strategy
resources committee of 20th of february
2020 if we can remember that far back
um it's on pages 7 to 14 of the agenda
papers
um
does it if i go through page by page
does anybody have a
comment or correction to make
as to their accuracy um 7
8 9 10
11 12
13 14.
are those agreed
agreed uh agreed
fine thank you
yes
[Music]
um item five in um public participation
to receive uh views of members of the
public which prior notification in
writing has been received
no later noon on the tuesday prior to
the day of the meeting
um
do we have any um anybody we should
participate as public um we've been
notified of anybody
no we've got none there has been none
thank you
fine okay then if we move on to item six
um uh a main part of the
uh agenda on it policies pages 15-32
um is um who is presenting this is it to
mr leslie or mr holly
um chairman mr mr leslie is presenting
it
fine thank you mr leslie
thank you uh chim
[Music]
okay so just to let members uh know
that uh in line with gdpr uh cyber
security
uh and other guidance uh norman district
council i.t
policies have been updated to include
the
uh latest standards for security and
behaviour
within the workplace in total
there are three policies uh to be
approved acceptable use policy using
email and digital communications
and information security policy
the acceptable use policy outlines how
any and all multiple council devices
should be used this includes laptops
tablets
used by both council members and
officers
the policy covers the obligations of the
users as well as the user's
rights to change uh to change the
systems he or she may be using
using email and digital communications
policies
outlines the user's responsibilities to
modern district council
and their clients the public when
replying to
or using uh forms of digital
communication
that could be email phone or text for
example
these policies explain how a staff
member
should reply and how a response
should be formulated uh when
representing morgan district council
the information security policy
highlights the importance of
maintaining security for the council
and its data as well as listing the
appropriate parties and their
responsibilities
for data security uh these updated
policies
are to ensure modern district council as
an organization
are aware of and complies with its legal
obligations uh to the public
and also those around uh data security
we also have mr holly here
with us this afternoon who will be able
to take any more
tech called questions uh around this
okay before i ask for any questions uh
um
mr leslie um can you say
how much of this is new stuff or is it
entirely new or
um should we say an update of um
anything it's
been existing
it's uh it's an update around some of
the existing resources
um i can refer to uh mr haley who it may
be
more of a run-through of exactly what
the changes
are around those mr holly then what is
new in this
so as an update um and specifically um
in addition to our e-learning basically
we've included a password policy
or more more precisely a stronger
password policy
again in london's with gdpr
recommendations
outside of that again these policies are
to reiterate
how staff and committees should be using
mandatory circumstance devices
so it's it's um confirming
what we should already be doing in
practice
thank you right do we have any any
questions to either mr harley or mr
leslie
and chairman councillor bamford then
cancer schemes council mrs channel and
then councillor
lagan have asked to speak on this item
thank you
mr leslie did say that these policies
refer to both count this council staff
and members and
although i haven't i admit i haven't
read all the
documentation in detail the
parts that i have read seem to really
refer to just
officers and the staff within the office
itself so um i just want confirmation
that all these policies actually do
address
the use of um laptops and ipads by
members
in their in their in at home and also
the fact that
officers use these um devices
at their home rather than in the
workplace so i just want to make sure
that that is covered
acceptably in these policies thank you
thank you um does uh
mr hulley want to answer that first off
yes chair thank you um so from the point
of view of the policies
um these blankets cover both office and
home use um obviously the device
devices are owned by modern district
council and we maintain what's known as
a locked
system uh the idea behind that is um
part of the security is obviously
software and hardware based um but the
other half
is then a physical practice um from as i
say members
offices etc um making sure that we don't
uh open incorrect emails
or reply in a way that's inappropriate
um so
so this does cover the whole council
this will be members offices all
students
etc um
thank you
mr councillor schemes i have next
i believe um counselor with penny
channels before me
am i wrong uh well i've yes i've got the
names down
in some order i'm not worried council
schemes
you know please go ahead i don't mind at
all the chairman's not
you know the order don't worry okay it's
sometimes difficult to follow the order
isn't it
yeah in these virtual meetings uh
yes okay um two things uh
just bear with me for a second while i
bring something onto my screen which of
course i've now lost control of
uh yeah the i notice uh email etiquette
uh and uh there's some useful advice
which uh
it's pretty straightforward avoid snap
responses never send an email
anger always good advice what uh what is
the
force of this uh what let's say that a
member does send an
email in anger and doesn't avoid a snap
response
uh what what happens about that
where does that go next if uh if
officers feel they've done that
is this uh does this affect the code of
practice
um thank you a counselor i don't know
whether mr leslie might want to answer
that one
yes thank you chairman so we obviously
have the guidance
set up in terms of those policies and i
think you're talking about actually
in terms of what happens uh should that
not be followed
for members and obviously there are
existing procedures
uh around that in terms of the code of
conduct
etc so we'd
follow those ones that are in place
around that okay it's just it wasn't
clear to me how if somebody
breached this etiquette that it fed into
the code of practice
but uh the code of contact rather a
second question if i may and that is
um in under the human rights act 1988
this is on page 24
second paragraph uh it says
um article eight of this act applies to
emails and digital correspondence sent
at work and gives
individuals a right to privacy however
monitoring
individuals email and digital
correspondence at work may be justified
if it's in accordance with the law
and is necessary uh could you clarify
what
uh the law is on this or could an
officer
clarify what the law is on this and
whether
there is at malden district council
currently
any monitoring of members emails
chair i'm happy to answer this that's
okay
so from the point of view of monitoring
um and first and foremost from a legal
standpoint
obviously members officers anyone who
works for malden district council
have the right to security the
definition of that
is as an example a director using chris
as an example
wouldn't be able to view your emails
cancer schemes as an example what
we are allowed to do though is data
which includes emails or texts or
anything that's sent out on behalf of
modern district council essentially
from a data standpoint belongs to that
organization
if there is a warrant so for example
if a director if a manager
feels that someone is being
inappropriate
it can implement monitoring
to check now that has to be very
carefully defined
what that means is i.t are allowed to
for example
check let's say a given month as an
example
if something is found in that given
month we can give specifics
to the requester which is almost always
a director in this case
however if nothing is found then no
information is passed on
so it's a case of monitoring to check if
required
if you see what i mean just to follow up
quickly if i may share um
have there been any recent cases in
which such things have happened at
morgan district council
i'm not asking for the specifics of the
case i'm just asking to know if that has
been done recently
um again as lead ict specialist there
have been two cases
in the last six months as an example
in both cases emails had to be checked
for a specific account
and in both cases i believe no
information was passed on so
yes and just finally on that uh were
if if your emails are being checked
let's say it's me
i've done something inappropriate let's
imagine um
would you inform the um
member after after the event or during
the event if their emails are being
checked
that's the thinking critical point for
me um
it would be after um so a check would be
run and then the
member whoever maybe may be made aware
afterwards
and but that's normally done by the
person doing the request
so the director for example can decide
whether
it is relevant or whether there is an
issue
if there is it can be taken further okay
so so in short
if my emails were checked by somebody i
would be told
for sure afterwards whether they found
anything or not
if required yes if required sorry thank
you
so yes fundamentally um if we have to
check your emails and as i said director
has requested this
the director should make you aware um
so yes is the short answer thank you
right can i uh then um and just raise
this question with them you
with mr haley or and or mr leslie um
there are different kinds of breaches
then involved aren't there
um if something could be a breach of a
code of conduct
um it could be a breach of this
etiquette that is
within these um uh codes of
i.t codes or it could be something that
is
actually um a question of lawfulness
or of an offense um
regardless of how it is actually
unearthed
and going back to what is the main point
of this particular
item um if something is not falling with
any code of conduct
um is there a separate um sanction
or set of sanctions relating to
breaching
the it codes
or would this be subsumed into somehow
written into the code of conduct of
members
uh is that one for mr leslie
yeah i'm happy to take that uh in terms
of sort of actions whether it be um
staff
uh or otherwise uh the iit policies
aren't
um uh don't don't have those sanctions
and they're not really
they're saying they should have the
guidance but we're not uh changing any
of the currently existing
processes uh in light of that so it
doesn't affect the
contact it doesn't affect you know the
staff contact side of it so these are
around
the policies and then if anything or any
action for any reason
obviously legal breaches may then be
going to the police
but if there's anything that does
require further action that will be done
uh along the lines of hr policies
uh for example so they are in place
these its policies don't change those uh
courses of action
so the sanctions aren't within the i.t
policies there are existing
things such as the members code of
conduct and ihr policies
which should be followed should there be
a need to
thank you thank you uh right can i go to
council channel then please
uh thank you very much chairman thank
you
um chairman yes um how do you
bring around these changes to the
policies i hear this is an update really
um now i do recall myself as a member
and i agree with councillor bamford
actually i read this and
an awful lot did seem to relate more
succinctly i guess to officers and
members
how is one going to know that um all
members or indeed all members of staff
are really familiar with these policies
and the clarity of them
i think at one time there used to be a
form that was signed so can you tell me
what process will be engaged
to ensure that officers and members may
have the best chance of actually
complying with
these documents and also i heard what mr
halley said about um
working off at the office or at home the
equipment is that of mdc well
only recently through council it was
agreed that we could use our own
equipment
guarding council as i understood it so
i would hope if i chose to use my
personal equipment i am not bound
perhaps by these policies then perhaps
like that explained although of course i
recognize
i may be connecting with the server or
something but we have been told that
so i'm not quite sure if those policies
cover that sort of aspect
and also on page 22 um chairman if i may
i think it was appendix two
there's three columns and it says
i'm sorry i have to look the other way
next i'm trying to read off somewhere
else because i
can't do it all on screen first comments
outside your normal working hours well
that's members we are
um often we get residents and that
urgent matters can be communicated by
telephone fine well that's if you know
the telephone number
um there isn't because we're not giving
them um there is no expectations you are
always available just because you have
connectivity
avoid peer pressure and do not get it
blah blah
it all and then middle column though
says by considerate of that being
considered at the time or something day
when sending emails blah blah blah if
you manage others
set an out of office response when you
are unable to read
your emails for at least one working day
so to me that in a way conflicted the
first column because it said
there is no expectation you are always
available just because you have
connectivity
and yet by the column second column
saying set out
and out of office if you're going to be
out for one day
that to me gives some in fact great
influence that in fact you
are expected to be there and answering
your emails with connectivity
and one day off or if you don't answer
that next day that could be an issue
um so and it says you're responsible for
running your work time and don't work
too late
well with members it's very difficult
i'm often working into the early hours
of the morning or whatever because
whatever stuff so i do agree with
councillor bamford but i am concerned
for the staff there
reading it doesn't mean you should
answer your emails because you just
connected but then you say
well if you're out even for at least one
day setting out of office on
and that will let people know you're not
going to be there that seems to imply
you there's an expectation you should be
responding
if not the same day the very next thank
you chairman
um thank you one for
mr harley do you want to take this one
then yes please chairman thank you
um so there's three elements here and i
apologize if i missed something please
do remind me if i do um so first and
foremost from the point of view of the
the policies um whether it be hrit
whatever the case may be
um the council has implemented what's
known as e-learning
now i believe each of you either have an
account or if you don't currently have
access we'll be getting access shortly
the idea of the e-learning which is
something that all the offices at the
council already actively use
is this lets them not only read the
policies
but also answer sort of a almost a
question and answer section
on it um to show their understanding of
those policies
um so our officers are required to now
complete that
um and that's actually done as they join
the organization
or of course for offices that are
already in place uh they had to do this
about
three months ago quite literally um so
yes we take
everyone through the policies step by
step and make sure it's not standing
afterwards
separately to that you obviously
mentioned you the use of personal
devices
now fundamentally a personal device
obviously belongs to
the user at hand and we don't
have access to that device what we do
though is or what we do control though
is the data that is then accessed
via that device an example of which
would be office.com
where any of you could sign in to access
your emails
you are signing into a portal at that
point that portal
we have control over so whilst the
personal device is secure
and belongs to you and obviously not
checked or
monitored as it were um the portals that
you're accessing from all the district
council are
so so we have control of those um again
that's where the monitoring and that
side of thing comes into play
if ever required um lastly and again
hopefully not missing anything um
obviously you mentioned the email policy
as it were um
coherence responses um contact with the
council things along those lines
um now first and foremost it's best
practice that if an officer goes on
a holiday for example that and out of
office is implemented at that point
so normally that would be implemented an
hour before they leave
the council building or whatever the
case may be
so from the point of view of um enacting
it within a 24-hour period
um i can understand that you know if
you're all for a week um
an officer might forget um but best
practice is to
is to activate that out of office prior
to leaving
that way a response is generated
as an automatic response that can be
anything from
um please reply to a different email
address or giving out a telephone number
or you know simply i am on holiday will
be back at a given date
um this is more to make the general
public yourselves for example aware
of where that officer may be at that
time so that you don't necessarily
expect a response quickly if the person
is away
finally just to throw it out there
obviously with the new phone system
we do have um obviously a central
mainline number
and that's triaged through our call
center to any given officer
whilst it's not actively advertised on
our website
there is a process where by completing a
contact us
form if the right sections are selected
a number is given
so that again is controlled access but a
contact number can be
granted if required okay
chairman i just have a supplementary
sure
yeah yes i suppose uh mr haley thank you
very much for that
um very fulsome response i suppose where
i'm coming from with the out of office
if you're out of office for a day it may
be that you're in meetings all day and
can't answer
is that the same self same expectation
um and then you should be saying i'm out
of you know at meetings all the while or
what have you and then you get a defined
person or whatever
i wasn't meaning it just in the context
of
holidays but i was meaning in the
context column one says
there is no expectation you are always
available just because you have activity
you know avoid peer pressure and blah
blah blah and do not get into
competitive situations over email
responses
column two then says if you're gonna be
out for more than a day whatever reason
this is how it reads to me you stick on
and out of office
so in a way i see a contrary sort of
meaning
between column one and column two
because
it says don't feel pressurized don't
feel competitive to answer emails but
then
column two says if it's more than one
day stick on and out of
well not more it's at least one day so
if you're out the next day or whatever
you've got to stick that on
so there is an expectation i feel that
you should be answering
very swiftly yes no fair enough as i say
out of offices obviously are
automated and it's the ib idea behind
them
um but i suppose there's a debate here
whether
we change the wording slightly to maybe
better explain
the out of office setup um so i'm quite
happy to obviously look at that if you'd
prefer
that i did i i can't say that on my own
um
mr hulley that would have to be for the
committee to practice give that steer
but
i'm merely raising the things that when
i read through the document i thought
you know engage thinking on my part okay
thank you mr leslie do you want to
contribute something there
thank you yeah it's probably worth just
um
adding from my perspective it's not uh
it's not looking
as people do do work it's merely that if
someone is away for for a day or longer
um that people are made aware of that
for example it could be perhaps
something
information is needed for whatever
reason um
and that they are aware that person is
um away
for the day they may then be able to go
to someone else and
get that information help the business
along so it's not to pressurize anyone
intention isn't to pressurize anyone in
doing work it's just to uh let people
know
that that person isn't available and
therefore
they may need to go elsewhere depending
on what they need or wait for their back
so it's more
about informing people that that person
is unavailable so
hopefully that provides assurance it's
not the expectation it's just
communication that a person isn't
available
thank you um it seems to me that when it
comes to pressurizing and
responding and so on it whether you feel
under pressure or not is largely a sort
of a personal
matter um obviously it's best question
of
best intentions to deal with a matter as
soon as one can
and now i had a counselor lagan i think
up next on the list
yeah thank you chairman um i'll keep it
succinct because most of the questions
and the points have been raised by my
other colleagues and other members
um the the the policies
are well written and easy to read and
predominantly to understand so i just
want to actually mention that
um listening is what other members have
said i think it would be
would be very valid if there was some
more clarity regarding
member responsibilities because as as
councillor channel says
we do work some very unusual hours
to ensure that we can respond to to to
queries as best we can so um and also
to be clear on the communication that
chris has kindly said
you know someone emailed somebody for
information that if that person is not
available there is a tangible contact
where you should go next rather than
just say
okay we've hit a brick wall so i'd like
to see
if that's possible and the committee
agrees that
some review only minor is there to get
that clarification for members
and also to be very clear that there are
places that you need to go
if the person is away thank you
can i ask you councillor just precisely
what you would
how you'd like to uh and amend the uh
the text then i'd have to i'd have to
put some text to
some ideas to the members to go to the
offices but very something very simple
just like a member section just to say
you know the expectation of members is
you know members work outside the normal
nine to five or whatever the world work
actually is now
just so that he's really clear and
there's clarity between the expectations
of officers
and what we take on as members so just
something in that nature
okay mr hulley um if what council lagoon
has said is just a matter of um
uh clarification and um tidying up the
wording
he could uh he could just um suggest to
the old
change here or there couldn't he is that
the way you see it
yes of course and again so if you're a
counselor if you're happy with that
that's fine um
we're more than happy to obviously see
the addendum and and add as needed
so yes if it's a matter of clarification
um then you can probably deal with that
then
yes then lastly i have a at the moment
councillor darum
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much chairman
again i'll be brief um because again
most of my questions have been answered
but um there there's a very fine line
between etiquette and a more serious
breach
and i'm wondering uh who
makes the decision which side of the
line a particular email or
correspondence might fall
i'm guessing the monitoring officer um
or is
or is this going to be you know decided
after a complaint
is put in about a particular
incident and i just want to go back on
something mr leslie said
he said that access to a members or
officers emails mainly by a director
but i actually have a file of hundreds
of emails
that were requested by a fellow member
through a data subject
access request so anybody is entitled
any member of the public
in fact can make a request to see a
member's
emails um so i just wondered if mr
leslie
could uh clarify exactly
what would be required should a member
of the public request to see a member's
email trials
thank you um yes before i ask mr leslie
on that um
the first point that you made counselor
dom seemed to be to um
to split into two parts one is
identifying a potential or possible
breach and then who would decide whether
it
was a bridge or not um and the question
is who
what does the um the monetary process
to pick it up in the first place it
presumably would not be the monetary
officer
it would be prefer referred on to to him
or her
once it had been picked up by somebody
else um
chairman yes sorry just to clarify yes
as i said because it is such a fine line
um
you know surely somebody should have a
more detailed
um set of criteria to
make a decision which side of that line
it falls now
um it just would be interesting to know
who that responsibility will
yes thank you uh well it
depends on uh the type of incident
involved
these are guides around the policy
and how to communicate as i said before
this isn't uh a paper about uh any
sanctions
or anything like that this is the it
policies to uh
to follow um we've moved on to another
realm i guess of particularly looking at
staff
the hr policies uh the grievance
procedures
and matches around that and similarly if
we're focusing on the members side
there is the member mechanisms in there
for the code
etc around that so this paper isn't
about those
uh sanctions that are in place um
to do that i think when we're talking
about who decides
uh it will probably depend on what uh
what what occurs and these aren't
outside your sort of normal
uh routes and processes and procedures
uh
for sanctions um around that so
it depends what it is and then follow
the processes that currently
it exists around that and you're right
in cancer it could be possible that it
is the moderate officer
who decides uh along with the
constitution it depends
uh what it is and how it's dealt with uh
around that so in terms of the other
so an issue then it's likely to come
from somebody else referring
so that it can then be looked at it was
it's not as though we're talking about
monitoring in the sort of sense of
monitoring twitter accounts or anything
like that and it but it would come from
somebody
having an issue to raise a query
for uh id to pick up
or via the monitoring officer to ask ait
to pick up
yeah yes it's quite right it's not that
these things have been constantly
monitored or anything like that
um so it wouldn't be picked up through
that it would have to be picked up
through
an active route such as into someone uh
uh raising an issue with it
or being seen by someone who's copied in
etc
right it's not like an automatic process
where something will be picked up
uh it has to be raised and triggered uh
around that
so quite right would it be would be
right to say that they really
should all come initially through the
monitoring officer
to investigate with it or to take up
with it
uh i think it depends on what what the
issue is um
as i said this doesn't change the routes
that currently exist in terms of
processes uh for people to raise
complaints or otherwise
so those routes are still still there um
and i would follow those existing routes
as there is an issue uh
follow the uh the constitution and the
current processes that are in place and
certainly
for officers it's the hr policies uh the
main go to
uh around that okay thank you
councillor durham do you have any come
back on that
no that's fine i think uh it's just
gonna be a question of waiting to see
when these things come along
i mean i says i have a file of hundreds
of emails between two particular members
in a previous administration i might say
that ready in isolation were absolutely
unbelievably defamatory between the two
and these didn't actually come out um
until a third party got involved so
yeah i i i yeah thank you i accept
what's been said thank you
thank you i think uh councillor did you
want to come back on something
as well okay
um nobody else machine
to raise a question um if chairman
council mrs
thompson has asked to speak all right
okay councillor thompson
uh thank you chairman um actually i was
kind of
mentioned freedom of information
requests because um
oh my background's disappeared um but
councillor durham already
has and i was just going to suggest that
you should probably all bear in mind
that
practically anyone can look ask
practically anything at practically
anytime
so it seems worth the point worth
bearing in mind
um but i don't actually use any moulding
devices i only use
my own so a question probably for mr
hully through you chairman please is
um are the malden systems affected by
our
use of for instance anti-virus software
or
lack of it i mean obviously we're still
open to pressing the wrong button on
a dodgy email um but to what
extent um could the molden system be
compromised by something lacking in our
own devices systems
thank you all right yes
mr holly are we at risk thank you chair
um thankfully the the short answer is no
um
because we're using portable interface
um you can't
easily that's worded that way put for
example a virus from a personal device
to
office.com or to one of our servers for
that matter
it's worth mentioning that one thing
that we um
don't suppose members at the moment is
our vpn system that's our virtual
private network
which is something that officers do
regularly use which is why officers
generally use my industry council device
and then has the vpn on it
again lock system so personal devices
aren't a threat to
to our organization thank you that's
what i was
hoping to hear thank you thank you
chairman fine
thank you mr holly um so
uh to wrap this up then um should we
thank the um office of pursuit for
producing report
and um and adopt it i suppose
and chairman sorry to interrupt you
again council mrs chan has asked if she
can raise another question
please counselor
uh thank you chairman oh sorry i
couldn't unmute myself quicker i've got
a problem with these headphones still
seems i have to do it manually to unmute
even though i can hear you through my
headphone
um yeah it goes back to you to counsel a
scheme's point and um
in fact mr holly's response to that um
regarding members and
our emails being looked at for whatever
reason and we should be told
it could be the director uh i actually
think we do have a right to know
and i think that should be actually
clearly identified and written into
whatever policy is applied
that should it be a member and their
emails are looked into and
um mr haley did then say yes they should
be told
um i think that needs to be written down
just for clarity to ensure
that perhaps those that do do that um
recognize the responsibilities that they
do need to inform members
because i'd certainly want to know if
someone was looking at my emails for
whatever reason
yes thank you thank you councillor
mr yes mr leslie um
there is an issue here as to whether
people ought to be notified
that their emails or whatever are being
looked at for
some reason um whether or not anything
transpires from it
um because there must be must be some
reason lying behind it
should um if it is possible that uh they
if there's any individual fathers
there's no objection to that you can see
to people being notified of that we
probably ought to um make that
amendment um
yes i think i'm happy for that to be
there
i just like just to refer to um mr holly
just to make us aware of uh
any sort of legal issues etc but in
principle
i don't have an issue with that and it
seems to be good practice
thank you yes there's a is there a legal
aspect to this then
if notifying people in that the emails
are being looked at um so i suppose
again
there's two elements here just to be
aware of um firstly from a legal
standpoint
no we can obviously make you aware if or
when your emails are being monitored but
i do think it's important to note
here as a committee that you see the
data and the access we're talking about
here
belongs to molding district council as
an organization it doesn't belong to
you as a counselor or myself as an
officer
so there is that legal side of
the data isn't yours and we have to
protect it
so we have to be aware of that as well
that
yes what you just said seems to actually
reinforce the
point that counselor chandler was making
about people being notified that
their emails are being locked up yes
there's nothing
nothing this is nothing uh breaching any
any legal or gdpr requirement to
if to let them know yes and again
as we said earlier um if we put an
addendum in there that just
essentially is a line that states that
we will make the person
involved away aware that's that's no
problem we can add that
yes i think that might be helpful
chairman because the reason is i'm a
data controller i understand as well
and therefore if someone's looking at my
emails and might see names or people i'm
having email exchanges with
of perhaps the residents particular
personal private matters
then i would want to know about that
because to me
i understand it's the mdc system but
equally they're my emails coming to me
from a resident or whatever person
and therefore being a data controller
i'd want to know who's looking at
perhaps my communications of a highly
you know uh private sensitive nature i'm
having because
um i wouldn't want to get held up and
i'm sure if something went wrong i
can counsellors not be held up alone as
data controllers or is it the authority
that gets held up to account
should a breach be inadvertently done i
am a member
disclosing something they shouldn't
essex there's a very good
rider we have at the bottom of our
emails to help overcome that issue
yeah so the questions of some of those
emails effectively
containing confidential information
sorry
um yeah so um again i apologize
counselor channel um uh this is a bit of
a supposed harsh response um
when it comes to being a data controller
and from the point of view of
email access personal emails or emails
of a personal nature
shouldn't be on a company account and
they need to be segregated
that is to prevent issues like this
um if it's work related then it should
be on a work account and that work
account is what could be monitored
um now as i said informing the party of
that monitoring isn't an issue
we can address that but from the point
of view of the nature of the emails
by definition of them being on a work
account or
council account they are no longer
personal
at that point it's it's a work related
email i think mr holly must may have
understood me i'm talking about personal
and private from the term
in the case of the resident coming to me
such as
they do come on and i don't actually use
my personal
equipment for emails uh with people
residents come to me because i'm their
board member
well one of the world members and it's
plastered on the website how to contact
me
and therefore what i'm saying is those
messages from
their i'm talking about their personal
business to do with whatever issue they
may have
it could be enforcement where
enforcement members are even told it's
highly confidential
so it could be on an enforcement matter
so if i've got an officer and i'm not
trying to be
accusationally i'm just saying i'm just
trying to be clear on this if we've got
matters such as enforcement or other
issues
on our computer and we're being
monitored or these are looked at
then being the data controller i mean it
could be other things i have had some
people come in very personal private
issues
um health it might not fall into them
but it could actually be to do with
benefits
you know i may have a number of people
so that's where i'm coming from
being the data controller they come to
me now if i pass it on
an ordinary i do because often i have to
go to an officer but what i'm saying is
i'm in control of that
if my emails are being looked at for
whatever reason
whether it's me being monitored or
someone else then that's where i'm
coming from really
where does that leave me as a data
controller with no knowledge
of what may be being looked at which
might have highly personal sensitive
information
not about me but about the people who
come to me because i'm those of elected
member
who can represent them yes
yes mr harley yes so as a
response to that um yes fundamentally um
they can email you on their private
nature to a work account whatever the
case may be
um yes at that point i suppose you are
as a data controller controlling that
email um
obviously as the data controller for the
council
we do have or potentially have the right
to monitor that
um i think we do need to put that
addendum in then stating that
for example you would be made aware if
monitoring was taking place
but other than that i don't see a way
around
around this issue as it were the data is
in
a work account that work account belongs
to modern district council
as the data controller for that if we
receive a request
we're allowed to essentially control
that data
mr leslie is there a problem here
no i just got to clarify that actually
the council obviously has a data
controller itself uh does have to comply
with the data protection
act 2018 uh the same as councillor
channel is saying
and therefore we're by those issues of
confidentiality and how to treat
personal data
exactly the same as yourselves so we are
bound if it comes onto our servers our
systems
etc we will need to abide by uh
to keep that data safe to keep it for
only as long as needed
etc so we are bound by that and the data
will remain
confidential in that sense if there is
any uh
need for it to be given out
etc then there have to be good reasons
um
and we will comply with that
confidentiality um side of it so we are
required
to uh follow the act as well so it is
kept safe
along those lines um so
if there's confidential information
between councillor channel and a
resident
um is it and that becomes confidential
to you is it a different sort of level
or definition of confidentiality of you
you become partied to what was
confidential between
council channel and a president um
well they're kept confidential uh
as you'd expect so now when we follow
the data protection act
uh that we're bound we're bound by so
that does remain confidential um
yes we can yes i wonder whether you
could check what the situation is with
um
with mr quelch on the the so we say
extending comfort or broadening um
and confidential information to
somebody else even if it then is held
confidentially
um i i i think there was a sort of legal
issue here which
would be worth clarifying um
[Music]
could you do that happy happy to speak
to our data protection officer
around that but obviously our systems uh
look at that and our systems comply
with that and of course the email system
is maintained
uh by the council and therefore is part
of our
systems and part of the work that looks
at our data protection
as well so it is picked up as part of
that
[Music]
get some clarification for the committee
yeah so i think there's a question
here of um
confidential information as far as
councillor chen is concerned
and confidentiality within your
orbit uh whether there is a a legal
conflict there
if i can ask you to have a look at that
with the legal officer
um maybe you know it's the way around
that or maybe there isn't a problem
um if i can go back to the previous
point
about being advised uh if your emails
are being looked at
um can i ask members of the committee
um if there is sort of general agreement
that we should
um put add that in
that people should uh notified if it is
being
if their emails are being looked at or
does anybody
disagree with that i see council
terrorism
yeah chairman certainly when this has
happened in the past that's always been
uh
that's always been done i mean on on
several occasions
uh when i was leader uh the monitoring
officer came to me and said there has
been a request so
i think yes it should be put into the um
should be put in into the policy but i
think it's probably already happening
and i would have said it's etiquette as
much as anything else
and if i can be really cheeky chairman
and just ask um something from
a comment that's just been made under
the data protection act we're only
obliged to
to or we're only allowed to keep
information for as long as it is
necessary
can i ask mr leslie um or mr hulley
how long are members emails kept on the
system for please
all right i'm happy to take this
challenge
at this point in time members emails as
well as officer emails
are stored for seven years um although
in planning
um and so mapping and planning it's
worth mentioning that they stalled for
up to 50.
um so yes those are the two breakdowns
did you say 50 yes for planning and
mapping
fine okay um well if it's general
agreement perhaps we can
put that into the document that people
should be advised if their
emails are being looked at um do we have
anybody else
wishing to speak on this particular
agenda item
um yes chairman counselor lagan has
another question here which is to raise
please
okay councilman yeah thank you chair you
made a comment earlier on about you feel
these policies should be adopted but i
think
with the robustness of the debate um i
think we we should wait until the
editions have been
uh the addendums have been addressed uh
the member section has been clarified
and then come back and then
been reconsidered for adoption so i
don't feel at the moment unless
unless what we've just debated and made
recommendations come into the
documentation
until the amendments have been clarified
and the policies come back to the
committee again
for ratification okay
um that's
reasonable isn't it mr leslie
yeah of course uh just be helpful uh for
the minutes just to ensure that
um all the members uh proposed
amendments
have been captured that's probably the
only comment i'll make so
so we get it right um
i think there was an amendment of
wording suggested by councillor lagan
early on
there's this point about members being
advised
uh if the emails are being looked at uh
i don't recall any other amendment we
were particularly
concerned to make or am i wrong on that
councillor lagan
uh yeah thank you i think just for
clarity chair i think i think the
document would read better if it had a
section for members
so really succinct information that
members have
picking up on what council channel said
elegantly earlier on about
we work on different times so the the
reasonableness of responding to emails
needs to be really clear within that and
also that if
emails are to be looked at that the
members and other people are actually
informed up front
i don't think there needs to be anything
more to it than that
but i'd just like to see it included so
you can see the flow of the text before
adoption
okay right um are you crying with that
link out uh mr leslie
that was helpful for clarifying
appreciate that thank you
all right okay thank you um and and
chairman
will the committee also be given um
obviously you've asked mr leslie to go
and get the legal review on some of this
will the whole committee be notified of
that chairman the outcome of that
um well i certainly hope so um
it's really a question for mr leslie to
establish is a legal problem here or
conflict
um and certainly that should come back
when we
get this sort of tied it up version next
time
fair enough mr leslie yeah i'm happy
uh happy to circulate uh just a briefing
just to
inform uh members of this committee so
briefing to all members of the committee
we should be able to do that next time
then we tie this up
um councillor stops you wish to say
something
um thank you mr chairman i just wondered
if it would help if tara could put
up those amendments so that we can
actually see him in writing
um whether that
could be one of the moment it might be
worth um actually circulating an amended
um
section or amended text to members in
advance of the
uh report coming back well chairman i'm
i'm
i'm happy have we i think we might need
to have a proposal here for
it from the committee to show agreement
so i'm happy to
i think if council against was a clear
proposal i'm happy
to second that but you know perhaps
cancer still
might be if we have got to have a vote
or anything then it might be that
council still
feel happier seeing the actual wording
so we know what we're voting on
i'm happy i think
the amendments are made along the lines
that have been discussed but the actual
wording of it
um uh probably is best well thought out
and then circulated so that members can
um
take that into account when this um i t
policy comes back
no pardon i don't know
we want to look at some wording now do
you
um perhaps it would be helpful um
council nagan's proposal
was that the adopt the adoption that the
account the committee not adopt it
and that they wait until the addendums
have been addressed and then
reconsidered so from that my
understanding is he's actually
asking that the policies come back to
the next meeting or to a future meeting
following amendments and obviously that
might be wrong if i
misunderstood that counselor megan but
that's what i was understanding from
that
and from also it'd be useful to
understand if that is in respect of
all the three policies or if it's just
in relation to the email communications
policy
thank you chairman
the email policy only
right um well we if we
um take that as a straightforward um
recommendation or motion that uh
we uh do not adopt a policy until we've
um
had an amended version and then
that's quite straightforward
is the general agreement on that then
yes chairman i don't think it would be
right to to
to reword these on the hoof i think it
needs to be done
properly uh and in a considered way so
just
just deferring it to the next meeting i
think is the best option
yes chairman i have asked to
um speak on this to guide the officers a
bit
because i think um it's not all three
policies it is two policies
page 17 of the first policy which is the
ict
acceptable use policy on under the
monitoring
section we need a paragraph there
and on the appendix 2
email and communications we need
a paragraph relating to members on page
22
about use of email etiquette
that's how i see it following the debate
that's where the two amendments need to
be added
right and well we've been we're not um
tying it to just the
communications one and i'm sure mr
halley will
um um examine any uh sort of
implications for the other policies as
well
um so it will be the whole set to come
back to us even if it's
uh only an amendment amendment here and
there
and chairman sorry to interrupt and we
that's not what council lagoon was
proposing so i think we perhaps just
need to
revisit his proposal if that if that's
not what
you're that you're thinking differently
he did indicate it was just the um
the email communications policy
well can we go back to council lag and i
mean if there are
um sort of side effects on the other
policies they ought to be taken into
account
wouldn't they uh yeah i
don't i get i get the point chair um i'm
happy to go with the majority members
but i i think
in this state and to move things forward
it would be more expedient for us to to
not accept the suite of policies
uh for the officers to go and to to look
at the uh relevant amendments because i
think they've got the expertise and the
field
for what the debate uh brought out into
into the forum
and for the officers to then send a
draft amendment
round to us as a committee and the
committee as a whole
consider those amendments make comment
and then they can come back to the next
strategy resources committee
so that is the proposal i'd like to
table chair
and not not not tied only to the
communications policy but uh obviously
to the whole
set we might as well do the whole set
because it's uh
if there's anything that cross sex cross
references and i have read them but i
can't read them
spout them for bait and chair so i think
it probably would be
better to make sure that they're crystal
clear water tight
and serve the purpose that they need to
serve i don't think we're talking about
a massive amount of amendments chair
and other members i just think what the
debate has said is is very relevant and
another few weeks on this won't do any
harm
the counsellor schemes here to second
that
yeah i agree yeah bring it bring it back
as a proper job
yeah i agree with that um
right okay yes um well um
is that that's agreed then it goes back
to
uh uh mr leslie and mr halley
uh to take into account the um
amendments that have been uh recorded
agreed okay agreed
upgrade agreed agreed
thank you thank you around to our agenda
item seven please
um consultation on changes to the
current planning system
um on pages 33 to 46
um mr lee i imagine it's going to
represent this mr lee
thank you chairman um good evening
afternoon members just too
too much in autopilot um
members have to report in front of them
in relation
as jeremy said changes to the planning
system for clarity just want to
say that members may be aware that there
actually are two consultations
ongoing at the moment and this
report relates solely to um
the changes proposed the current
planning system rather than to the
review of the planning system so it's
just a point for clarity in case any
members have got any confusion
in relation to the members matters we're
talking about which are quite different
to some of the others that you've
probably seen
in the press um the office report
highlights what is considered to be the
main four
issues within the consultation which are
changes to
the standard method for assessing the
housing numbers
relation to delivery of first homes the
need to support small and medium-sized
developers
an extension of the permissions in
principle
they those are detailed
within the office report in sections 3.3
3.4
3.5 and 3.6
attached also as appendix 1 is
the the officer's success suggested
consultation response
in relation to these changes
as members will be aware when change
legislation are brought forward
um we are consulted these
consultations are limited
as in it's not bespoke it's not free
they ask
set questions um so quite often there
may be points that other officers or
members
generally the council would like to
raise but they're not really
available um so the
appendix one lays down the 35 questions
that
have been provided by the government and
office suggest responses
um to form modern district council's
response
and that is what the recommendation is
that the committee agrees that
and that that is therefore goes forward
to the government
thank you chairman um
yes thank you mr lee can i just to
clarify
um the situation um the
35
points in the consultation that you've
provided answers for
um very carefully and capably
um are they not prefixed by the general
proposals that are made
such as on zoning or is this um
are these matters and the question of
substituting sustainability
soundness are these issues that are
going to be subject
to a separate um criticism
and report by the council at some stage
yeah thank you chairman um yeah as i
said for clarity there are two
consultations ongoing at the moment one
of which
has a uh consultation closed on the
first september
um that proposed which this report is
proposes to whatever benefit were
tweaked
to the existing system it doesn't need
any primary legislation it can be
changed through secretary legislation
the
variations of the mppf etc the point
around
the zoning and changes to the local plan
and all those suggest all those other
suggestions that's under the white paper
which actually there should be a report
at the next committee in relation to
that consultation so they're
two separate um
how whether or not these changes
are in reality are fairly short term
because of the white paper may change it
all
it's a bit of a matter for debate and
probably not really relevant to this
because we are just
we've been asked a question or 35
questions in this case
and we're just providing our response
but yeah i do get your point about the
fact that
it may be a bit of a moot point and it
may only actually have a very limited
impact
thank you chairman um yes sir mr lee
then
would any changes to the nppf
we um require legislation then changes
the mppf don't require any legislation
the mppf can just
is a government document of guidance and
it can be changed
overnight um for example the ppg that
provides additional and more detailed
guidance
is regularly and i mean very regularly
updated offices
or councils aren't even told when it's
updated is we just have to constantly
review
and make sure we're not using outdated
guidance so and that's all
none of that is with any uh consultation
or
anything that just can be done as and
when they see fit
right thank you um right um
any people who wish to um comment on
their mistakes you know this i
see councillors durham initially
yeah thank you thank you chairman yeah i
i think um
uh we i was briefed as uh through essex
county council i think
uh councillor bamford was there at the
same time i understand that there's a
consultation
response um being put together um
jointly with essex county council annie
power
so it's a an essex wide consultation to
this
you know obviously from our point of
view the
the concern lies with the 102 increase
in our annual
uh housing allocation which is uh
which is a a you know grave grave
concern
but you know quite clearly and as mr lee
has pointed out
the the potential uh and indeed the
chairman
the potential changes coming from the
white paper
uh are far far far more uh
wide-reaching and have far more serious
uh consequences
uh for the authority not just in the way
uh it
operates in terms of planning but in the
financial aspects as
well with the abolishing of section 106
and sil
and the proposals of what's going to
replace that is is again quite
unpalatable how that will work
so um yeah i i just
would just like to ask mr lee if uh
our response coincides with uh that of
their power
and uh and the um and the county
council's response please
thank you chairman um yeah i was
actually in a meeting this morning with
the uh
the power in relation to um the joint
response obviously
obviously but obviously there is a
difference between let's say what we
would want to say exactly as an
authority
highlighting the points that impact us
very specifically to a more broad brush
stroke response from
that we're looking at doing as essex and
also as uh
through power but yeah so but we are all
working together to ensure that there is
a
generally consistent and cohesive
response going out
to be honest i don't think anyone's
really raised any particularly
different issues or anything to be
honest thanks
and i determined if i might just come
back i think you know
particularly critical in from a modern
perspective
because as i said we've seen our numbers
increased by 102
the next highest is rochford at 60 odd
percent
increase and there are several districts
where their housing annual housing
numbers have declined so
you know we've actually we've actually
got the raw end of the deal there so i
think you know we we do have
um additional concerns over and above
greater concerns over and above that of
other districts but thank you
yes thank you well i should have
something to say about that 102
increase later but initially um
i'll call for any other members
who wish to comment uh
bamford and then councilman they have
asked to speak thank you
okay then
okay councillor bamford person
thank you chairman um this follows on a
bit from what
council durham has said um and i think
it would be useful
if our officer can explain to this
committee
that this standard method of assessing
housing numbers
um is something that we can't change
and that has what has resulted in this
102
increase so
you know this is our issue so i think
that would be one thing i would ask
um perhaps matt lee to explain to this
committee
the other points i wanted to make were
on some of the answers to the questions
because we as molten district council
are one of the only
authorities that have an adopted local
development plan
and i think we should emphasize this a
bit more in the answers to these
questions
and actually um be a bit more
um give more information
about our position in the answer to the
questions i know
this has happened in some cases but in
particular
question one the answer to question one
i think should be um there should be
more
emphasis on the effect it has on our
authority which isn't really emphasized
in that answer
there are also some answers to questions
which just say
no yes no comment and i would have liked
to have seen
um officers actually explain why they
have said
yes or no or no comment rather than just
saying that
i think it would help um you know
to give a reason why they're saying that
so
that's um my points chairman thank you
right and mr lee can i ask you
first of all uh we're just to put on one
side this question of the standard
method because that is what i want to
talk on
um we could objective um
can you say the address the other points
about
whether we can make much of the fact
that we've got an adopted ldp in some of
these questions
um and uh
on the other points about the questions
where you've not had any comment um
is is that do you have any comments
thank you chairman sorry i'm just trying
to click
um i don't sound flippant members but
obviously
when we've got no comment generally
officers haven't got a comment um
i know for example like question 10 when
we put no comment
that's because it relates to question
nine um
we haven't really as an authority we've
had no dealings with anything
where there has been an exemption for us
as a district
um so officers are not
confident that they can give a fair
response to actually how
where and when they've been effective or
not effective or actual the impact of
those
um we haven't experienced that so we
don't think for example that question it
would be appropriate really for us to
provide a comment um generally though i
know some of the questions
our responses are in some places fairly
small but obviously there will be a lot
of responses so
you know in some place we've tried to
keep it as small as possible to actually
hopefully
um give it some value and
well like question 23 for example where
it's about you know can you think of any
ways that the government can support
small and medium enterprise builders
well actually the answer is no we don't
consider there is much more they can do
without
not through the planning process anyway
and
similar thing with a lot of the
permission and principal stuff
um you know the questions are pretty
to the point um but our answers are
similar so yeah obviously if members
consider it some it does need to be some
expansion on certain points we can do
that but
i'm not convinced how much value that
would add
um yeah i'm thinking questions 24 and 25
about the extension of the commission in
principle
um whether
one could give any sort of backup to
that
um on question 22 yeah i think with
question
24 he's quiet to the point but
that's then got other questions below it
i think that sort of fill out
the thought processes behind that
um
so i think yeah
question 22 um
yes i was going to ask him um about this
um
definition of rural areas i mean how how
tight or
vague is that at the moment obviously
it's guidance it's
all quite fake we haven't actually got
definitive legislation
to be honest that's which is some of the
for one of a bet you know officers have
discussed quite a lot these questions
are quite a long time they've looked at
more independently we try to come
with a general consensus but one of the
issues is
there is and i never like to make
assumptions there has to be some little
assumption in
what the question and what the changes
actually would be because there is not a
full level of detail at the moment and
generally as you can probably guess it's
normally vague rather than precise in
most instances at the moment
but i know somewhere else it refers to
designated rural areas
yep um what are they
they are specifically allocated sites
such as i think it's like i o areas for
standing beauty and things like that our
district doesn't have any
so um yeah so to be honest i'm not i'm
exactly i want to go for the extensive
list but i know we don't have any so
it's not something need to know
definitively
right um council bamford do you have any
comebacks on that
thank you chairman um yes i think mr lee
has actually explained um why
he has put what he thought or rather the
officers have put that
but the point is that he has explained
it to us but he hasn't explained it in
the answer to the
questions that's what i was trying to
say it would be nice to have just that
clarification on why
it was yes or no or no comment
and my other point was question one
which doesn't explain the reasons
why this is going to affect our district
in such of dire way and i think it would
be good
to emphasize there what it will do
to affect our particular district and
the fact that we have an adopted
local development plan
but obviously this is um you know this
is just
my thoughts on this and i can appreciate
where mr lee is coming from but i just
think it
emphasizes our points as moulding
district council
obviously would like to make clear
members are aware that
the there is already a standard
uh methodology in place this is about
changing the calculation
um at the moment ironically
this might be as you know cancerdam
explained we've been very very badly hit
through this
um where actually in the current one
the number of houses actually basically
fool's hand and gloving with our
ldp requirements so it hasn't been an
issue for us when the
original process and requirement
to calculate this was brought in so for
us it was quite a
moot point and we we had concerns but
actually it worked out okay
for mdc but it's just that the changes
to it
are where the problem is and one of the
big problems is
is that the reduction in the 40
cat is to be abolished but also it's
the adjustments for the market
um which is about basically where our
prices about dwellings are quite
expensive compared to salaries
um so we are having to shoulder a burden
for that um my assumption is obviously
we've explained there's no guidance on
that
is that the government consider that if
you build lots more houses
it'll push the value down therefore the
local residents will be able to buy them
um
but yeah i assume that's the assumption
i know um
not necessarily always true but i think
that's the reason for it but that's
actually where
we are being so badly stung for one of a
better phrase
right can't take up some points on this
standard method then mr lee
um and it's you've added another
justification there for thinking twice
about
this um approach
namely its variability its capaciousness
um and the fact that we've had this
a big increase doubling of um housing
out of the blue just because of the
operation of a formula
suggests to me that there's something
wrong with the formula
if you guess a an absurd result then
there's something wrong somewhere along
the way
and i think the standard method should
be questioned
um not just this variation but in
principle
because of the components of it
i mean had a lot to do with this these
sort of
economic ideas and people trying to
reduce them
to statistics and it all gives an
impression of
objectivity neutrality um
moderation but they are inaccurate they
do not
this ratio is not a definition of
affordability
um the shortcomings are particularly on
the
earnings side the earnings are based on
workplace that is to say where people
have earned these
incomes which may well be out of the
district
in chelmsford culture store london
so it doesn't reflect the generally low
level of
earnings by people in the district
working in the district
the secondly the earnings figures they
use are gross
um so it gets skewed by the fact that
you've got any
higher earning earnings in it
which um uh where without
them which would pay higher rate taxes
um the next point is these
leave all large numbers of people out of
the equation
because it's only dealing with people on
company payrolls
and so it leaves out self-employed
it leaves out people on benefits at
least leaves out the needs that is to
save people not in
employment education or training um
and not to mention of course
all the other unemployed people um
people on very low
casual earnings so it does not recognize
the low level of local earnings
the ratio doesn't represent
affordability
it takes the median figures medium
sounds as though it's nice and
compromised
and so on but um the median
house price 350 000 perhaps
the median earnings of people in the
district
um well you can place your own figure
somewhere between 10 and 20 on average
um and to take the median figures is
totally pointless what we're really
concerned about with
his affordability is how do we provide
accommodation for people in that bottom
10 percent
of incomes and this doesn't address it
at all
um obviously there are various little
tweaks that
the planners um try and put in here and
there for percentages of affordable
housing
uh percentages of um social housing
whatever to try and
uh rebalance it in terms of changing the
structure of tenure um but to
then uh add on this idea that
it it's a way of allocating another 300
000 houses a year
is simply economically illiterate
um there is a flaw to the price level of
housing
and that's way about what those bottom
ten percent
the people who are really trying to get
into affordable housing
can manage so i i
individually um and whether the um
committee agree with this i think we
have to go back to
um whichever the ministry is
and question the uh relevance
of this standard method in trying to
address the question of affordability
thank you chairman um quite a long
question there
um as i said we've got to acknowledge
that
the consultation is only in relation to
adjustments to the existing
standard methodology and most of the
points you've raised to be honest i
don't disagree with a lot of them
um but they aren't up for negotiation
know not for discussion at this time and
we're not being asked to comment on
those we're literally being asked
relatively small i know the outcome's a
big difference but the principal change
is relatively small as in
they're still using medium but we're
still using house prices we're still
using salaries etc
and obviously it gives a skewed response
well you know that may agree that you
might not you know i have my own opinion
um but that's not my place to discuss
that
here um but obviously it gives a
response that it does and that
though is separate because we're not
being asked to comment on the idea of
that or the fact that that exists
and um but you know i think in relation
you say about affordable
housing and meeting the people in need
personally and i think offices
when you read our consultation response
we're more worried about the delivery
the first homes on the impact on that
in relation to actually meeting housing
need for the bottom 10 percent or bottom
20
of earners in the district that would be
a greater concern about that than i do
about the
changes in this anything else within the
what uh the
consultation for that impact thank you
chairman yes can this
be divided into two airspaces then
you've mentioned that the
capriciousness is yes mr chairman
could i interject um i have been waiting
some while to actually
um speak um would it would it be
possible
um to to actually ask a couple of
questions
um uh particularly on the housing needs
and in relation to
um affordable homes um in particular
um in the southeast i think uh
councillor bamford actually and i think
council
channel did as well highlighted that
there was going to be an issue with
um a lack of affordable homes and then
the first homes um uh
provision which ultimately um
looks at a 30 discount which is of no
consequence when you live down in the
south east
of england and i think possibly this
needs to be highlighted
um mr lee if possible um in in
some of our responses the second part of
that
is that there will be no cell attached
to these
um affordable homes so we have no way of
actually raising any um funding for any
sort of infrastructure
whatsoever so that is a real concern to
me
uh mr chairman and i and i really wanted
to to get this across
um i think the situation with kovic 19
has exacerbated our problems um
but we should not be using that as an
excuse
to push through um processes
um and underlying um
numbers um
we should not be using that as an excuse
to do this how can we go from 308
to a minimum of 434 homes
i mean we struggle with 308. you want to
tell our parishioners that that's how
many we're going to have to build
let alone the 623 a year
i'm not very happy with this at all um
and i just feel that this stamps all
over the work that has previously been
done
um under the ldp uh and it is basically
overriding it so what was the point what
was the point of the ldp
what was the point mr lee
yeah yeah mr lee i said i suppose it
it comes down to how you can express
more forcefully um in simply answering
these questions
the fact that it will have a significant
impact on our ability to
provide well affordable homes even under
this sort of definition
um you you do mention variability
um is that a way of one way of answering
this to say that
the application of the standard method
um is so variable that it's
unreliable and we a reason why we must
doubt the
increase of 102 that was mentioned well
i think
i think the changes um
i think the government what they're
proposing would argue that it's not it's
variable they've clearly made
authorities like us victims want a
better phrase of
a cultural approach that house prices
are deer in our district compared to the
salaries and therefore
you need to build a lot more houses to
push the price down that's their
conscious decision it's not that it's
um an obtuse variable that it's you know
it's rolling dice
the intro the changes they've made were
clearly you know if you just
read them off to me without even looking
at numbers i would know instantly
that our figure was going to go through
the roof um
without even having to look at anything
you know this is a conscious decision
by the changes to impact
obviously not on us specifically but on
authorities like ours where
um we have high house prices compared to
salaries
um but also the other issue is that
obviously when you set the questions you
get you get to choose your answers to a
certain extent and
some of the points that are being raised
here we're not even being asked about
um such as the fact that you know i've
got i said i've got concerns about the
fact that they're talking about
making a set percentage of affordable
housing
what would have been affordable housing
in the traditional sense you know which
would have gone throughout predominantly
probably gone through our
allocations possibly met the housing
needs of the district of the
people in the most need and this now
goes to
25 in relation to first homes there's no
actual question about do you think
that's an appropriate
approach there is none on that that is
just that is not for
they're not asking us our opinion on
that probably because they know that
everyone will say no
you can under the appropriate um answer
um say something
about the implications yeah we have i
think we've raised some points around
that but
the issue is if if if we're raising
points that aren't related to the
question
it's so when you go to an interview if
you aren't i'll always ask
you to answer the question you've been
asked not the one you wish you've been
asked i think
raising points that aren't relevant to
the questions we've been asked by
to consult on becomes
any relevance they just will they'll
just be parked they won't add any value
but i think officers have tried to do
that where we think we can in a
broad remit but there is only limited
scope for that i think personally
thank you chairman um i i um
i don't know whether you whether there's
any point
in the council making doing a sort of
covering letter to its response
to the consultation but um
do you think that um this should be what
do members think this should be carried
forward
on a different level to um highlight
this
impact of doubling the housing
requirement but chairman um
like councillor mays i've been waiting
to ask a question make a few points if i
man i don't know if i'll assist that
may i ask or do you want that don't we
first yeah i've got a number of names
you could
go ahead then i'll um i've gotta come
back to the on my other list afterwards
then
oh right okay i thought i was after
council amaze sorry that's what um
i've got from tara sorry um
yeah thank you um i'll try and nub this
down a bit
um and mr lee's just touched on it a bit
and
indeed other members have what concerns
me is well definitely
the way this formula now and the numbers
of houses that has been produced
um we can't deliver it i'm sorry i think
i'm gonna have to be as blank
um and blunt as that we can't deliver it
having worked on the lgp for numerous
years
um it's quite disheartening actually
having applied ten years plus it must be
dedication to that along with officers
and other members of course not myself
alone i'm talking about teamwork now
it's quite disheartening
i think what also concerns me is um you
know this is going to have affect i'm
not against first homes for young people
don't get me wrong i'm not
however it is going to affect quite
largely
i can see in my opinion us you know what
we ask for at the moment within our
policies for affordable homes
for the vulnerable and the elderly now
we have an aging population we know that
it's shown we are
in the top two of the demographics
indicator showing we are going to have
the greatest number of elderly
population
this is going to cause distortion if
we're not careful
um we won't necessarily have the young
people that can still afford the houses
but equally we'll find ourselves as an
elderly population
the affordability affordable housing for
those persons and vulnerable eg
shared rent or whatever and we're going
to also find other avenues where we're
in a position where we're talking really
about market homes here to a degree
to a higher degree i feel it in what the
you know the government are proposing
here
and also the exception sites concerns me
exception sites was always a case of
for affordable homes or whatever a
scheme that parishes would sign up to
it seems to me within what they're
recommending um
this would change so it would be first
sight um
you know first time buyers homes as well
come into equation
effectively sort of market homes to a
degree and i think that destroys some of
the ethos
and what we've worked so hard to try and
get parishes to sign up to
i i think this is going to lose a lot of
confidence within our communities
so there's an awful lot chairman that
does consignment and i think we do
um i tend to agree with you chairman i
know mr lees answered if we make points
that the question is not about they'll
disregard it
i think there's a way we can do that and
i actually think we've got to strengthen
some of our responses make it quite
clear
you know what this will really mean for
malden district what it will mean for
our elderly population our vulnerable
population
what it means for our young people as
well or the first time buyers market
this i think is very serious and the
bottom line is to me we can't deliver
what they
want to seek and i actually did read
somewhere this won't just be
um aligned to applications we haven't
got yet
i've read somewhere that it is also
about applications might be in the
system already
and providing it hasn't been too much
discussion or agreement
they would start applying this to those
applications and that causes me
great concern um chairman as well so i
think i've covered all the points if
i'll come up with something i forgot
i'll come back but i
i i think um with all due respect to the
government
um this is going to cause a lot of
problems most certainly for a district
like ours
and it's a great pity and great
i think i think there's a question how
we take those general problems
general issues forward but mr lee do you
have any particular
points to make on that thank you
chairman um
to be honest i don't disagree with
pretty much most of what council channel
said
um i do have great concerns with our
ability as an authority to deliver
these figures um and
it is disheartening for officers i can
guarantee you know where we've worked
hard on
uh advocate we've worked hard on local
plans we've worked hard on adversarial
applications defending appeals etc and
you know all of a sudden we're being
told that actually all that work
potentially was a waste of time for one
of a better phrase
um i think there may be a
potential or a different approach to
maybe responding to these questions
which are very generic that maybe the
authority may want to do
from mr dodson maybe um
in his name or the leader maybe in
relation to
the impact specifically on malden um but
i think that slightly
sets aside answering these questions
which are intentionally very generic
and i'm not convinced that adding
a particularly strong personal reference
those questions would add any value to
the
melting pot of considerations but
obviously that's up to
the member's decision but um i just
yeah just everything forward apart from
that
response to the consultation this
question of how we develop how we go
from here chairman may i come back on
that please
mr lee just regarding the answers i mean
there's any way we can beef them up
um i think there is a way perhaps we
could get some points underlined by
saying um when we answer and then say
we however we will really point this out
but i do think perhaps
um i'd like to propose as well chairman
in addition to this consultation going
off that we do actually
as a committee ask the to lead um a
letter
go from the the leader of the authority
um and you know and and the director
relevant director or directors on the
same letter
um whichever way might be best and we
send it in
but we also make sure we um send copies
to our local mps and i think we do need
to perhaps
we haven't had um some meetings recently
with our mps i think perhaps this is a
time now when perhaps we
we definitely need one chairman so i do
make that proposal in addition to what
we're doing in this consultation
response
we do get the leader um to do the letter
whoever however which way she
feels better with the director signing
with her or separate ones or together
i think we need a robust piece of
correspondence from our leader thank you
chairman
i oppose that way forward come out
i totally agree with that thank you can
i ask counselors
can i ask counselor bamford whether
she thinks this
should be done pronto or um
await uh the town the uh full
council meeting well the um
the response to this particular
consultation
um chairman is the first of october
so that's why it's come to this
committee um
there is another part to the um
the white paper there's a separate
planning white paper as well
which make will make matches even worse
so i think
perhaps in consultation with the
officers
i could um decide when the best time to
respond with a letter would be um
either now or later because the other
white
paper consultation it has got to be in
by the 31st of october
and i think um paul dodson our direct
director wants to come in on this which
i'll be grateful for his uh advice
yes i think it will be a separate uh
report to committee on
on chairman
make it clear my proposal was purely to
say that the leader
and the relevant director do a letter i
didn't put the time frame on it i felt
obviously that is not my domain to do
that that would
be if that proposal was carried from
this committee
for the leader and the relevant director
that what i was asking was for a letter
um this committee perhaps to ask for a
letter to go from the leader
a propo or rather a proposal from this
committee and if that's carried
then it would be for the leader
obviously um in the gift of the leader
and the director
to know what time i wouldn't def i
wouldn't like to be saying
this week next week or whatever i think
that's we have to give that
discretion to the leader and the
director i i would agree with you
and then it does mr johnson would say
anything at this
juncture yes thank you chairman um
just further to the the suggestion of um
councillor mrs channer and um the
leaders follow up on that
i think it'd be very appropriate um for
for that letter
to go for all of the reasons that the
members have flagged
um you know officers recognize how
serious the implications of these
proposals are
for malden district council and
i think the emphasis can't be placed
enough within the consultation response
to highlight those
so i think a separate letter is a very
good idea
i would further say that i think it
needs to go prior to the
um first of october which is the closing
date for this consultation to ensure
that it's considered
alongside the consultation responses
obviously the
the second consultation that is
happening next month
will is on a separate um item
so we should treat the the two as such
and make sure that we emphasize our
response on this one
thank you thank you thanks mr dodson um
do uh members generally agree with that
that they we ask them
suggest the leader in conjunction with
the officers
um write a letter to a company the
the um consultation response agreement
penny was proposed and second did yes i
agree chairman agree
okay generally agreed i think
um no there were still a number of
people who wanted to make
comments on on this um i think did i
say uh councillor thompson early on
uh no thank you chairman not on not on
this one although as you've given me the
chance i would like to thank mr lee
and all his staff for all the work on
this because it is
very well considered a document thank
you indeed
um counselor durham wanted to
raise a question i i yeah i've got
councillor dharam down
um i think actually council morris
indicated earlier he wanted to say
something
he is obviously not on the committee but
shall i can i ask him if he wants to
make a relevant comment on this
subject if he is still there
chairman i think that's i think that's
uh your description
for the committee necessarily to answer
yes i'll take committee members first
um counselor stills i think
wanted to say something
uh no no mr chairman i didn't okay
uh counselor directly
thank you um just a couple of very quick
questions
um if this goes forward
and the numbers stand i'm wondering what
the
consequences of us not adhering to these
additional numbers will be
i'm assuming that mhclg will step in and
potentially remove our ability to
determine our own
applications which is always their
behest
the other question is given that the
white paper consultation has to be in by
the 31st of october i'm not sure
on the committee cycle when the next
meeting of snr will be
but clearly because of its even greater
and far-reaching uh consequences
whether uh this committee might need to
meet
slightly earlier to uh agree
what is likely to be an even more
comprehensive response to that
particular
um item so as i said mr might be able to
tell me when the meeting is
but we don't want to leave ourselves
short of time
um prior to the closing date for the
next consultation
because as we've all pretty much worked
out
that one is is far more critical
um yes i agree we do need to have a
meeting if only to
take that uh specifically um mr johnson
is this uh already in the schedule in
some way
yes with thank you chairman we've
scheduled the um
draft consultation response to come to
full council
on the first of october recognizing the
importance of this consultation
and we wanted to get an early member um
steer on that
um to ensure that we can we can put in
that robust and comprehensive response
for the
the end of october thanks um
right we have the document well before
that then do we
we've received the consultation and we
have done the initial draft response it
needs some further work um
ready for the 1st of october but it will
be in front of council on the 1st of
october
chairman with respect i would have
thought that should come to snr before
it goes to full council
that would be the normal procedure
not for the time frames
if if i can reply chairman that that is
purely down to the time frames of the
the consultation that there was no
chance of bringing it to today's meeting
um and the the council meeting on the
1st of
october is the the only meeting in the
current schedule that enables us to
um bring that through for for member
discussion
thanks sir is there a district planning
meeting scheduled in that period
uh i think there is but
i they wouldn't have delegated i'm
actually probably stepped on paul's
mr dodson's toes actually because i was
talking about the planning committee
i'll be quiet
no no it's it's fine i'm only shaking my
head because
agreeing with with matt to say no it
wouldn't have delegated authority to
deal with that response
um it's not within the remit of the the
district planning committee
no no i was thinking i'll be
substituting as an son our committee
unless of course there is a necessary
agenda for the district planning meeting
through chairman um there is a
district planning committee and i'm
aware of at least one application on
that agenda so
um there's a need for it yeah and it's
got a ppa on it so we won't be able to
knock that
further into the long grass
unfortunately thank you
okay um yes uh mr johnson is there any
chance that uh the
the draft that you um or the report you
would intend to make to the council
could be made available a bit earlier um
to members of this committee
i'm involved in the process um obviously
the agenda comes out
a week in advance anyway um
the first of october is only 14 days
away
officers haven't at the moment finalized
the response to be honest we had two
very long meetings
on it yesterday i think it would be
very difficult for officers to be able
to give us a
substantive and solid response to
members of this committee before the
week
preview required for a normal
agenda okay
in fact i mean obviously there's a
there's a great advantage in having all
members involved in discussing this it's
so important
um um right
so it's generally agreed on that letter
being sent then by the leader
in conjunction with the directors um
so it can't you want me to come back on
council dumb's question about
the impact if we don't well i guess
that's related to
the the white paper isn't it it just
means that
there's a if there was zoning um
it would be open season on any zones
wouldn't it oh
i think in relation to cancer dance
possible queries but
it it's not a case of we won't be able
to be able to pick or choose
whether we use them or not they will
just replace our figures
um if we're not doing that we have a
impact on our five-year land supply for
better
terminology and obviously members are
quite aware that
that's quite a difficult
thing for us to maintain at the time
anyway so um
i'll leave it at that at the moment just
in case anybody's watching but
i would have grave concerns about the
potential impact thank you chairman
thank you now i think there are quite a
number of people who want to
um speak um
[Music]
but actually this a bit i have them
hands from mr dodson and um
counselor durham tara do you have
anybody else on
chat who's asked to speak no chairman i
don't
okay well then i better take um mr
dodson first
sorry it was my hand was still up from
before i've taken it down
okay thank you back to councillor darwin
[Music]
then
cancer durham
chairman i think like um mr dawson i
think his hand is stood up from before
oh is is counselor not with us now then
yes he's still with his chairman okay so
no more speakers on this then
no not that we've been advised of
okay fine um
but i think we know where we're going
with that um
mr leed uh are you going to try and um
put some additional beefing up in um one
or two of the responses
that's what the committee would request
i'm happy to
do that um right i
don't know whether we would need to see
that beefing up would we
um it's just if you've got any
justifications or backup material that
can
uh yeah chairman may i please propose
that um
that the um responses are um
beefed up in the private and i would
suggest actually probably the lead
because as the leader is going to be
doing
a separate letter um you know on this
same subject matter would that not make
sense
in consultation with the leader and the
director the
questions might be beefed the answer
would be beefed up especially question
one
and then of course that that the leader
then will know what's
going to be mirrored to assist the
letter that she may be doing
um with uh mr dodson or however that's
carried forward chairman
yes thank you
sounds right agreed on that okay
um i've lost my agenda but i don't think
it's much more of it actually
um any other items of business
uh which i do not have um
so i think that's uh time to close the
meeting then
thank you very much for taking part um
it closed at six minutes past three
thank you very much